This video is brought to you by surf shark VPN.
Hey, wisecrack Michael here and today, we're talking about the boys.
The show is sadistic and hilarious and has plenty to say about the superheros
genre and modern day America. But as we watch season two,
we kept coming back to one question. Are any of these characters for real,
when Stormfront or Billy or Homeland or talk about things they extensively care
about? Are they just faking it? And if so, why?
All the posturing let's find out in this wisecrack edition on the boys season
two, and of course spoilers ahead.
But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor surf shark VPN.
It's no secret that you don't have much privacy on the internet these days.
However, there is a way that you can protect yourself online,
and that is by using a VPN,
a VPN sends your information through an encrypted tunnel.
So you can safely use your passwords without the fear of hackers,
stealing your information.
A VPN can also protect you from targeted ads and to other pesky data trackers.
When you use search shark VPN, you can use your account on any of your devices.
So, you know, you're always protected.
They have over a thousand servers in 63 countries and offer additional features.
If you use the link in the description and use the promo code wisecrack in
December, you can get surcharged VPN for 84% off its normal annual price.
Plus four extra months for free go to surf
shark.deals/wisecrack, or hit the link in the description,
protect yourself online and download surcharge VPN today.
And now for a quick recap,
the boys is the story of when Billy butcher and his crew of vigilante misfits
were trying to take down the Vaught corporation,
a very evil company that employs and contracts out the services of often
evil superheroes.
What happens if, um, I dunno, I do this.
You're just another useless blind guy.
It's important to note that these superheroes aren't some happy accident rip to
Bob Ross, but the result of bots, very secretive,
definitely illegal medical experiments on children.
The boys try to expose vaunt and save Billy's wife and her child from their head
soup Homeland season two also introduces the latest Vaught hero
Stormfront who turns out to be an actual century old Nazi.
Kamala.
And so if it seems like the boys is full of people, espousing, disingenuous,
politics, and posturing for the cameras.
It's because the show goes to great lengths to show us how almost every
character is constantly performing after all.
It's not enough to simply be a hero in this world.
You have to play a hero to superhero star in movies, title card,
Dawn of the seven. Go on talk, show circuits.
The storefront, congrats on the seven. Are you most excited to be here as I am?
No, I don't think so.
Even give those lame midnight religious infomercials, but thanks to the church.
Of the collective. I know now the kind of man I want to be, Hey dude,
that's not cool.
Even when they're not on the screen, they worry about public approval ratings.
A 0.1 and a half, two.
And fastidiously, try to keep their personal selves in check.
Oh my God, everyone is still being stage managed life.
Isn't actually PR.
Strategy. You can say what you think.
And it's not just our superheroes who are constantly putting on a show,
whether it's a Becca plane house with a sociopathic Superman or Congresswoman
Victoria Newman whipping her base into a frenzy.
Every character seems to put on a mask at one time or another.
So here's the question. Wisecrack.
What do you think happens when these deliberate performances collide with hot
button social issues? Well, we've got a term for you, virtue signaling. Now,
before you smashed that dislike button here,
me out virtue signaling is a term that gets thrown around to suggest that people
are disingenuously, engaging with social issues, not out of genuine concern,
but to promote their own self image while it's certainly a real phenomenon.
It's basically become a catch all term to call anyone who cares about anything.
A fraud. One might say that even my discussion of virtue signaling is in itself.
Some kind of signal,
a virtue about how wise I am in an effort to make wisecracks seem Trey woke.
And then if you get mad at that and tweet about it,
your righteous indignation could itself be some virtue signaling to your
impassioned fans. Acquaintance,
it's very easy to call just about anything virtue signaling.
And it's also often, but not always a lazy and incoherent argument.
And it's confusing because we live in a world where we don't trust anyone to
stand for anything for the right reasons. And the boys takes this confusion.
Head-on the boys is centrally concerned,
not with how ordinary people display their supportive social issues,
but how corporations do in turn.
It explores how ordinary people end up consuming information about those ideas
in season one, for instance, VOD, rebrands,
their heroes Starlight as a feminist icon.
She transformed Grace's her feminine strength, goodbye yellow brick road.
Hello.
Starlight.
Except well, their brand of female empowerment through sexuality.
Isn't exactly what the budding superhero had in mind, but doesn't care.
They're more concerned with the image of an empowered woman that people can also
audible. Then, you know, actually empowering anyone.
Most importantly, it tells a story of your transformation
of what you're going through. How exactly do you know what I'm going through?
Exactly.
AKA virtue signaling the Starlight rebranding helps their bottom line rather
than any feminist cause a similar conflict happens in season two,
Homeland or maliciously outs, queen Mave.
Who in the seven is gay queen Mave.
Revealing her.
Ex-girlfriend who Mave is then forced to pretend is her current lover,
Vaught reimagines maze forced outing in their film,
Dawn of the seven as a wholesome coming out story complete with a cliched love
interest in the form of a counter-culture computer hacker.
I'm afraid too to show the world who I am. Yeah.
So who are you made HUD gay.
After establishing Mave as a icon bought capitalizes on it to sell it like
this.
Right? Because you can't be prepped on an empty stomach.
It's worth noting that while Mave bars are sadly fictitious,
this whole using someone's identity for profit is a fairly common advertising
strategy.
While your head of digital marketing may genuinely care about say racism,
their message is still getting filtered through the lens of what's going to make
us money. As a result.
Most companies only support social issues after they become massively popular
and therefore safe.
Like how shampoo conglomerate L'Oreal posted about standing with the black
community this summer, despite Oh right.
Apparently ending their partnership with a model in 2017 because she spoke out
against white supremacy and filtering social issues through the lens of profit.
Isn't just massively annoying.
It can actively harm people take may of sexuality.
You know, maybe Mavis by, right? Yeah. You know what? I'm just feeling.
Lesbian is a bit of an easier sell, but more cut and dry.
Clearly vaults preoccupation with gay rights is just another sales tactic.
Not in earnest means of celebrating Mave for who she actually is.
The company then tries to overhaul the image of May's pretend partner, Elena.
So she can better conform to the stereotype of what a lesbian should look like.
That looks like men's wear few research shows that two feminine women in a
relationship since a problematic man.
This is the danger of virtue signaling as marketing strategy.
It puts a corporate friendly face on social causes, thus obscuring.
The actual reality people are then bombarded with images that reinforce the big
business version of reality.
And this sort of corporate do Gooding often provides a useful and deliberate
distraction from a given businesses, less savory practices.
This is well-documented and Fran Hawthorne's ethical chic in vaults case.
All the feminism and gay pride distracts people from the reality that the
company is a private military contractor with a less than stellar human rights
record. And this way we might better appreciate the boys.
Most glorious jab at Marvel for context and season two Vaute is going
all in on female empowerment with their new PR campaign girls. Get it done.
Tell us a little about how girls get it done, girls, get it done, girls,
get it done, girls. Get it done.
Idea is that since there have never been three women in the seven before,
now's the time to cash in, on not being sexist anymore,
but for all the congratulatory talk,
female empowerment is pretty much the exact opposite of what Vaute is actually
about. For starters it's newest film the Dawn of the seven.
Isn't exactly concerned with portraying realistic female characters.
All women is either unknowable, Hitchcock, or Michael Bay.
I'm going to get that a lifetime drinking off the transformers.
Didn't exactly make you popular ladies, but, um, well effort would be nice.
Literal Nazi saying this,
and it's not like the company has embraced a girl power off the screen.
Either recall are coerced into spandex. Starlight.
Confine was mailed outfit. Why not?
All of which brings us to that Marvel scene to summarize.
There is one very notable moment in a vendor's end game.
When Peter Parker asked captain Marvel,
how she plans to get past the incoming onslaught of Badman in response,
the Scarlet witch, and a coy pop in and say.
She's got help.
As more female heroes swoop into help. When I saw it,
tons of kids went eight because Marvel was finally letting their female heroes
shine. But for more jaded adults, this all felt a little forced.
Exactly the kind of corporate feminism that we'd become wary of.
And the boys seems to agree mimicking Marvel scene in the Dawn of the seven.
Get through all of them. Don't worry, girls,
get it done.
Much like Vaute celebrates their girls. Get it done.
After years of being a total boys club.
Marvel scene is a weird victory lap for a company that waited a whole decade
before putting out its first standalone female superhero film, captain Marvel,
which also happens to be a movie that many have called a thinly veiled
recruitment tool for the air force.
And so.
And that's not by accident.
The us military has often exerted editorial influence over movies like top gun
or captain Marvel in exchange for access to CIC tanks and planes,
the results a scrappy,
but not too rough around the edges hero who can be turned bolt into a toy line
and an advertisement for the U S military.
Spirit of her.
That sense of humor mixed with total capability and whatever challenge comes her
way is really what air force pilots are.
The kind of hero who would never ever do something like kick a person while
they're down and yell.
See in the brand safe virtue signaling realm of corporate social justice.
Everything has to play well with the large audience.
And so all the corporations who sponsor pride parades want to ignore that.
The first pride was actually a riot incited by police brutality or how those who
vaguely stand against hate on Instagram.
Never want to go into the details about what that actually means,
but the boys does.
It looks like this three women giving a bloody beat down to a literal Nazi.
Also congrats Marvel.
You've been roasted now a common problem with the way the word virtue signaling
gets thrown around is that the term seems exclusively used against the left.
So a sensible question would be is virtue signaling confined to the liberal
sphere. And the answer to that is absolutely not.
We just don't usually think about it in those terms to see what I mean.
Let's look at the King of conservative virtue, signaling himself Homeland,
or if virtue signaling is the invocation of issues or values out of
self-interest rather than genuine concern,
then this is Homelanders patriotism to a T.
The dude does not give about America or American citizens,
but he goes to great lengths to seem like he has a raging hard-on for the troops
and the land of the free. Oh.
And, uh, you guys,
you are the real heroes.
Not only that our sociopathic soup is a very careful to invoke all those cheesy
patriotic platitudes when addressing crowds.
[Inaudible].
This rhetoric we might add is common to all politicians,
but especially those on the right.
But if you have scissors or they're amazing soldiers like I have,
you would know that freedom comes at a price. Of course,
this is the same guy who down to a whole airliner of American civilians before
casually flying off and letting them sing to their watery graves to see how
shallow all this patriotic posturing really is.
You need only to look at what gets Homeland or upset,
not the deaths of innocent Americans,
but rather those rare moments when he isn't showered with love and adoration.
For example,
when people come after home Lander for accidentally killing an innocent
bystander, we see the strongest man in America breakdown
Of course,
a home Lander isn't alone when it comes to virtue signaling via patriotism VODs
is arguably just as bad on one hand,
the company turns out pro military ads like this one we're proud of.
To fly alongside them. And now we could use your support that's right.
Made with our new campaign saving.
Sort of like that captain Marvel app, right on the other hand is Stormfront.
So rightly points out. It's all a farce.
Oh, FYI, not a real base.
See like Homeland or Yvonne.
Isn't interested in actual national security or supporting the troops.
All they're interested in is those sweet, sweet military contracts.
Only one company that has the product to fight back.
And to that end, avant does everything from blackmail,
sitting senators to imprisoning and experimenting on innocent civilians with
compound V real good job, keeping America safe.
There's also a kind of Christian virtue signaling, you know,
pastors who get rich and famous for signaling to the world,
how much they love Jesus. Even if they're sleazebags.
She's all that gray, the gateway he's the Lincoln, the man.
Like that. And finally, there's what I call authenticity signaling,
which is all about broadcasting,
how real you are as best embodied by Stormfront. Be a.
If you want, be whatever, just drop the mask once in a while. It feels good.
Of course, her persona is also carefully crafted,
meant to rile up her base for her own gross ends.
But because she defines herself in opposition to her squeaky, clean heroes,
her own performance of realness finds a receptive audience.
Outlander and nave. We're going to eat MRAs, a ditch with the rest of the group.
With all this virtue signaling coming from both the left and right from
individuals to corporations, you might be asking yourself one simple question.
How did we get here? Virtue signaling. Even if it wasn't called,
that is quite old. They even complain about it in the Bible.
When Jesus said you needed to shut up on Facebook about buying a stranger
Starbucks. Well, I'm paraphrasing, but that's basically what he's saying.
But our current virtue signaling hellscape may be at least partially the result
of one industry,
public relations or PR ever since Ivy Lee,
the founder of modern PR first repaired the Rockefeller family's Robert Barron
image through heavily slanted press releases and a highly choreographed sympathy
tour through Colorado.
The world wised up to the fact that a little positive publicity goes a long way.
Of course,
people maligned Lee as a hired slanderer and poisoner of public
opinion. And maybe they had a point because here's the messed up thing.
Wisecrack, a hundred years ago,
Lee opened up the flood Gates and now the field of positive spin can be used to
rehabilitate the image of just about any one or anything.
And that's where things get dark to see what I mean.
Let's look at the messed up journey of the guy you love to hate the deep AKA
Aquaman,
except he does sexual assault after being booted from the seven for sexually
assaulting Starlight, the deep spirals heart,
eventually getting some time in the clinker for commandeering a kid's water
park.
It's supposed to be fun in the Mariana trench.
When he's bailed out, though,
it's by the church of the collective who in exchange for his bank account,
agree to do some serious PR work to get him back into the seven. To that end,
the church makes the deep appear in some seriously cheesy infomercials and even
focused has a wife for him.
I thought I got to choose you do. And you're choosing Cassandra.
Now the running joke of the season is how truly pathetic the deepest and how
willing he is to go along with a PR blitz that presents such a patently false
image. But underneath the humor,
we have to realize how fundamentally screwed up all this is through the
persuasive dark arts of PR, the deep, a repeat sexual offender,
and nearly regains his position in the most prestigious paramilitary
organization in the world.
Coach Malala, you subsized tweet called you a sweetheart. She's a sweetheart.
But if you think it's terrifying that PR can rehabilitate a piece of like the
deep, then you're going to love this next one.
The boys shows how PR and all its virtue signaling can even make.
Nazi-ism look kosher to understand what I mean.
Let's look at home Lander and his new boo Stormfront by understanding the
ins and outs of PR Stormfront is able to revitalize Homelanders flagging all
American brand. You don't need 50 million.
People to love you. You need 5 million people.
You have fans. I have soldiers.
Their word Stormfront and true.
Don Draper fashion knows how to sell a message to the masses,
basically Homeland or takes all that patriotic virtue signaling he's known for.
And appends it to a violently xenophobic message.
And the results are downright terrifying.
Nation. Under God, remember
godless in human supervillains started whoring across our borders and
dragging us down into their money.
It goes without saying that neither Homeland or nor Stormfront cares about this
supposed super terrorist threat,
a threat we might add that was literally created by Homeland or himself has ever
occurred.
Knew that a soup terrorist showing up
exactly when we needed him to was pretty
incredible coincidence.
Instead, all the spin serves the purpose of a larger darker message.
A race war led by Ava Bronto.
They want to wipe us from this earth just because of the color of our skin.
Really it's called white genocide.
Stormfront intuitively understands that if she wants to sell her vision of white
is right. She needs to dress it up with all that classic American Apple pie,
virtue signaling, or in her own words.
People love what I have to say. They believe in it.
They just don't like the word Nazi.
It's also interesting to consider that storm fronts own brand of realness is
just another cynical way to brand herself while VOD might traditionally favor
the more buttoned up approach of giving speeches with talking points.
She prefers crafting any more unpolished brand,
but a brand nonetheless paying people to make means in packaging people's
bigotry, right?
This is just the first batch I'll have Logan punch up the fear, Logan,
my main queen.
Now the trouble,
the virtue signaling is that many sociologists and philosophers have said that
basically everything we do is a performance.
Whether you're going to church pursuing a career or getting a sweet new set of
truck, nuts,
everything we do is filtered through how we think others will perceive our
actions.
As long as you're a trending, right?
If Starlight wants to do good and be recognized for it,
it doesn't necessarily make her good deeds worthless.
The problem the boys wants to remind us is when people weaponize good acts to
distract from their evil acts and with the world full of marketers and PR reps,
it's often hard to tell the difference.
So it's just business than I, when Mr. Butcher in history,
has it ever been about anything different.
But what do you think wisecrack is the boys' rights?
Can we even begin to decipher what's real anymore?
And does it even matter smash that subscribe button like Homeland or is okay,
we can't show that. Don't forget to ring that bell,
huge things to all our patrons for your support and as always,
thanks for watching later,
[inaudible].